الرصاصه واحده في قدم عمران خان كانت
كافيه لتهز باكستان اليوم تدخلها حاله
طوارئ عامه محاوله اغتيال لرئيس الوزراء
السابق صنعه الحدث واربكت كل البلاد
العمليه وقعت تحديدا في منطقه وزير اباد
باقليم البنجر بالشرقي هناك كان عمران خان
يقود حوارا سياسيا ومسيره الاحتجاجيا
للمطالبه باجراء انتخابات مبكره اثناء
مرور موكبه تم اطلاق النار عليه وعلى
انصاره ما ادى الى اصابته بعيار ناري في
القدم واصابه عدد من اثاره بجروح
المظاهرات التي كان يقودها خان جاءت في
اطار مسيره استهلها الجمعه الماضي من
مدينه لاهور نحو العاصمه اسلام اباد في
اطار حمله للمطالبه بانتخابات جديده
[موسيقى]
من يقف وراء محاولات اغتيال عمران خان
يقول مسؤولون في باكستان انه من الصعب
توجيهي اصابع الى جهه معينه حتى لحظه
توقع اكثر من مره احد مطلق النار الذي
اعتقل اقر بانه اراد قتل خانوا انه تصرف
بشكل مستقل لكن حسب الانصاف الذي راسه
عمران خان اكد انها محاوله اغتيال سياسيه
متهما رئيس الوزراء ووزير الداخليه
والاستخبارات بالوقوف وراءها وداع الحزب
انصاره للقضاء
[موسيقى]